ich will meine irgendwo drehen
zugleich soll das würde ich auch
verstehen dass kamera ein paket an den
sieg in denen später die stehen da die
pollen allergie ich wünsche euch einen
wunderschönen guten morgen meine lieben
freunde es ist ich hab' ich habe keine
ahnung 10 uhr 42 so früh ist jetzt auch
nicht mehr hat er mehr als eine art
revanche vor monaten gekauft hatte ja
keine blog geladen habt wisst ihr dass
er alles gar nicht weil das meiste ist
die zeigt einen halt immer an wie man
sich bewegt habe ich hab noch gar nicht
bewegt man neige ich jetzt zum sport was
ich eigentlich gar nicht darf weil ich
mich gemeinsam kochen lesen lernt jetzt
überall preis kann mit verletzungen
gefunden
endlich hat das genäht werden müssen
aber ich habe einfach drauf gekippt die
fand ich jetzt wahrscheinlich mit schlug
wie kommen wir dazu der ehre dass du
mein tier blogs zum desinfektionsspray
oder sind sie zu wenig bestellt
ja und jetzt endlich auch mache ich
irgendwie zu wenig bestellt oder haben
schon gemalt und youtube sind ja einige
felder den letzten monaten ganz ganz
ganz ganz ganz ganz ganz ganz viele
videos von mir und plötzlich nicht mehr
wer freundlich fast kein geld mehr
verdienen habe kurz auf der straße gilt
doch jetzt nicht wieder da wo er jetzt
aber irgendwann kopf bekommen in dem
video direkten daumen runter gibt und in
die kommentare schreiben
und übermorgen
ich bin jetzt das komplette wochenende
als es ist kein frei tag 10 uhr 46 und
ich bin das komplette wochenende in köln
weil sandra geburtstag feiert diese ich
wieder da kommen wahrscheinlich auch ne
menge andere blogger hin ich sie shady
und so wieder ich sehe ein paar andere
kollegen von mir wieder wir gehen morgen
also samstag die mir in die soccerhalle
ich nehme eine rauschbrille mit das
heißt damit wären wir noch ein bisschen
was machen denn falls ihm verzeihe
zurück nach hamburg und ich dachte mir
nämlich das schreibt auch nach dass ich
diese kamera mitnehmen fällt übrigens
hab das ding so lange nicht an gemacht
dass ich die gerade erst mal neu
konfigurieren musste mit zeitzonen und
den ganzen steht also falls du das seht
meine kamera ich habe irgendwie aus
versehen auf indonesien gibt allerdings
habe ich jetzt erstmal in corona test
und geht danach ins gym
ich trainiere seit ein paar tagen
[Musik]
keine ahnung was sie hier machen aber es
sieht so aus wegen der filmszene werden
schlussendlich zwei sekunden lang ist
und dafür brauchen jetzt den ganzen tag
dann auch zum ersten mal genügend zeit
wenn auch nur vornherein geplant und
stressfrei und pünktlich ankommen werde
update wir wären eigentlich pünktlich in
nicht eine person eine blase von der
größe eines tischtennisballs hätte wir
sind in köln angekommen und jetzt werden
wir auf seinen geburtstag gehen und da
kommt jetzt paar ausschnitt von
hernandez geburtstag angerufen gut so
luca wird es zwar rausschneiden aber
guck mal sein sterben schön kann man
schon mal selbst einem schlüssel geil
das war ganz schön synchron das ist
meine mutter fragen was im detail wissen
wir danke ich gebe lukas auf heute eine
glasklare 12 15
besonders mal sagen ich bin auch dabei
ja und da muss schon auch sagen ich bin
halt heute fast nackt deswegen sich so
ein geiles spiel vor
[Musik]
ich weiß ich weiß
damit sind alle sind habe ich mir keine
sache überlegt und zwar werden wir mit
der alkohol brille auf den torwart
zugelaufen von der torwart bin ich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
enthüllt wird umgebaut
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich übrigens frank wo meine haare sofres
sind muss die nicht wahr
geschnitten francesco benini
ich habe die links in die mehr nasa als
rechts ice cream united bestes in köln
auf der ganzen welt eine gute kamera
einstellungen sowie geht es ja auch noch
skala von
dabei ein bisschen durch
durchweg besser als junger lehrer hat ja
so ein räudiger ich meins kompletten
studentenalter bar was flüchtling tode
ist ein angezogen ging ja nicht verlernt
geflogen weil jetzt ein paar stunden
hier und wir machten wieder aufgenommen
jetzt gehen wir tatsächlich feiern denn
in köln ist irgendwie erlaubt in clubs
zu gehen
es war einfach wirklich ein
unglaubliches wochenende ich hab ne
menge menge freunde wieder gesehen an
der stelle auch noch mal ein dickes oder
lukas podolski
dank dir es meine kamera ist schrott der
teilt volle kanüle hiergegen geballert
und jetzt wird der schutz nicht mehr ein
und die schlimmen reparatur kostet 1000
euro an der stelle mich dem blog ist
allerdings ob der liebe freunde das tut
mir leid das ist total ist hin und her
war und dann habe ich mal wieder gefilmt
daran ist der vergessen dann kann damit
eine szene mit myphone gefilmt dann
wieder hier mit der kamera dann die
hintergrundmusik bei den tonen ich jetzt
ist die kamera und auch kaputt aber ich
kenne nicht ich kann das eigentlich
nicht was ich in meinem beruf
trotzdem gefallen hat dann das gern ich
sollte einfach aufhören mit diesem
youtube link